you are a 20-17 nickel fella I didn't
know what's gonna go this far I really
did I'm gonna try to not freak out on
camera and do it after it's hard to put
into words how much it means when I
found it at one I'm pretty sure that I
was babbling incoherently I remember
saying thank you over and over again oh
thank you thank you thank you so much
thank you anything to do with the
Academy is kind of like my benchmark or
my dream
the earliest story that I found that my
mom saved for me I wrote around five
years old the story goes like this there
once was a princess but she did not have
no ham thank you so much guys we're so
overjoyed
Bert yeah it's right I mean I process
our process mine is just to you know
write a terrible first draft and then
hand it off to Jenna and my process is
just did make it better this has been
such a ride I mean this is the best
competition ever you prepare yourself
for rejections I mean let's be clear
that's what my life has been about you
know it was completely unexpected and
I'm just so completely delighted thank
you I'm really really flattering and
glad that you like this trip and I'll do
my best not to disappoint you and thank
you so much probably I mean I think all
of us would sit down there right fade in
with the hopes that one day we're gonna
be able to walk into a new theater and
see one of our stories come to life
sorry we're really we're just really
happy yeah thank you thank you so much
[Music]